das higgs teilchen ist wirklich ziemlich
mysteriös und jetzt könnte es sogar zu
einer neuen physik führen
das higgs-teilchen verleiht allen
anderen teilchen der masse wenn sie
welche haben und immer mehr
eigenschaften des higgs teilchens werden
rekonstruiert und das könnte uns zu
einer ganz neuen physik führen klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasste nicht herzlich
willkommen ja klicks um heute aus köln
entdeckt wurde der fixe teilchen im
sommer 2012 am large hadron collider lhc
am cern
es war eine riesige sensation denn damit
hatte es knappe 50 jahre lang gedauert
die theorie des schottischen physiker
peter higgs experimentell zu beweisen
dafür war der lhc der größte
teilchenbeschleuniger der welt gebaut
worden
der beweis für das sogenannte
unsichtbare hitzfeld das allgegenwärtig
ist also das ganze universum durchdringt
und dafür sorgt dass fast alle objekte
eine masse haben
dieser mechanismus wird oft mit einer
cocktailparty verglichen diesem
gleichnis zufolge verteilen sich die
teilnehmer und teilnehmerinnen einer
politischen party gleichmäßig in einem
raum bis schließlich die ehemalige
britische premierminister margaret
thatcher das zimmer betritt die anderen
menschen im raum versammeln sich um sie
und bilden eine menschentraube
jetzt ist also nicht möglich den raum
einfach so zu durchqueren
hier wird masse verliehen denn die party
teilnehmer und teilnehmerinnen denen sie
sich nähert wenden sich ihr zu und warum
weil die leute tuscheln schau mal her
ist dieses getuschel löst also eine
zusammenballung aus nichts anderes also
als das gesuchte higgs boson sie bewegen
sich durch ein feld und das wird so
verzerrt der hilfsmechanismus ist also
vereinfacht gesagt ein hintergrund fällt
das erfunden wurde um teilchen masse zu
verleihen schon 1964 hatte der schotte
peter hacks diese teilchen theoretisch
vorhergesagt demnach ist das universum
mit einer art quanten sirup gefüllt die
mix fällt dieser quanten zero brems die
teilchen die durch ihn hindurch fliegen
diese gewinnen an masse je stärker ein
teilchen auf der cigs fed reagiert desto
mehr masse hat es dann kann es wiederum
auch das higgs fällt leichter in
schwingungen versetzen der nachweis
teilchen 2012 am cern
lange auch als beweis des feldes das
allgegenwärtig ist und fast allen
teilchen keine masse verleiht das higgs
boson wird so manchmal auch als teilchen
gottes bezeichnet peter hacks bekam 2013
übrigens den nobelpreis für physik
doch die entdeckung der higgs teilchen
ist noch längst nicht alles denn damals
konnten die experten und expertinnen nur
grob beschreiben wie es wohl aussieht
und wie sich verhält schließlich gab es
nur wenige messdaten das große problem
das higgs boson lässt sich nicht lange
beobachten denn sofort nach seiner
erzeugung zerfällt es in andere teilchen
und nur diese zerfallsprodukte können
gut nachgewiesen werden es handelt sich
also um mühevolle detektivarbeit die
eigenschaften des higgs teilchens zu
rekonstruieren dennoch konnte so stück
für stück ein steckbrief des higgs
bosonen zu einem echten winzling
erstellt werden das teilchen wie 225 mal
10 hoch minus 25 kilo also ist etwa 130
mal so schwer wie ein proton im sommer
2018 dann das nächste highlight einem
cern forschungsteam bars gelungen den
zerfall eines explosions in zwei
sogenannte bottom quarks nachzuweisen
eine echte premiere und meilenstein in
diesem forschungsfeld denn der nachweis
des bottom quark zerfalls bestätigte
erneut das standardmodell der
teilchenphysik denn die produktionsraten
der bottom quarks beim mix der fall
entsprechend genau denen die zuvor in
theoretischen modellen vorhergesagt
worden waren
doch nicht nur das forschungsteams
versprechen sich durch das
higgs-teilchen noch viel mehr vielleicht
sogar die entdeckung einer neuen physik
jenseits des standardmodells dazu eckert
elsen vom cern mit unseren experimenten
kommen wir dem wesen des higgs teilchens
immer näher
dem teilchen das auch als portal zu
einer neuen physik gilt genügend fragen
sind also noch offen zum beispiel warum
elementarteilchen eben die masse haben
die sie haben immer noch sind
forschungsteams nicht in der lage die
masse der teilchen aus einer theorie
heraus zu bestimmen also theoretisch
herzuleiten der hilfsmechanismus kann ja
lediglich beschreiben wie teilchen zu
ihrer masse kommt hoffnung setzen die
fachleute auf den ausbau des large
hadron colliders der gerade vonstatten
geht das upgrade des lhc soll es dann
schon bald erlauben seine eigenschaft
näher zu definieren und zudem sehr
genau zu messen wie es entsteht zerfällt
und auch mit anderen teilchen wechsel
wird konkret wird das cern die anzahl
der kollision pro sekunde von einer
milliarde auf mindestens 5 milliarden
erhöhen dafür sollen nicht nur mehr
protonen zu kollegen sondern der
zusammenstoß auf 8 statt 60 mikrometern
fokussiert werden 16 mikrometer
entsprechend 0,0 1 6 millimetern dazu
der cern generaldirektor fabiola
gianotti der ausgebaute llc wird die
ursprüngliche mission erweitern die
eigenschaften von teilchen wie dem higgs
boson mit grösserer präzision messen und
die fundamentalen bestandteile des
universums immer tiefer erforschen ja
ich war ja da am cern und berichte über
den auswahl des large hadron colliders
der large hadron collider wird zum super
beschleuniger hier anklicken anschauen
und wenn ihr klingt noch nicht abonniert
haben sollte dann abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran